I'm gonna tell you story at first it's  gonna sound ridiculous crime violence  and fear have run rampant our great city  is being destroyed people want justice  restored to this world people want  heroes we believe in you are you only  the legend or are you the truth behind  the legend we need fire Julie Emrick  fighting for love  yeah  this is your emergency broadcast system  announcing the commencement of the  annual purge there is a new enemy out  there  it's a miracle we've been given a second  chance you secret's safe with me  was some what you do so we know you've  been searching for one thing your whole  life sometimes what you're looking for  is right in front of your face  no your back  don't be afraid open your eyes  you